oh
god this is like bottom of the barrel
youtube bad hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today i will be chatting about keto and
intermittent fasting enthusiasts
everyone's favorite doc dr eric berg but
first let me type on my sponsor kettle
and fire so i first tried bone broth
during my sibo saga and while i never
really got into drinking it on its own
i became obsessed with using it in place
of basic broth or water in recipes to
bump up the protein and nutrition but
catalan fires become our go-to because
it's the first shelf staple nationally
available bone broth in the states
that's made with high quality grass-fed
and finished beef bones and organic
pasture-raised chicken bones plus
veggies herbs and spices they use a
really slow simmer time to extract the
maximum amount of nutrients amino acids
and collagen-based protein so a cup of
kettle and fire in place of water and
recipes can add 10 grams of quality
protein that's a huge boost in hunger
crushing compounds and rich flavor they
carry a wide range of products that
include vegetarian options as well
actually they even have a whole new
cooking broth line and ready to eat soup
line as well i've talked about the
emerging research on collagen protein
specifically right here but i'm
personally quite encouraged by the
positive findings for joint and bone
health and since it's just such an easy
simple way to get more protein in my day
it's something that i can just add to
the recipes i already love so if you
want to try out kettle and fire to bump
up the protein content in your meals and
snacks check out the link in my
description to learn more and you can
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my general
disclaimer including a trigger warning
for those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel if you are new here and ring
that bell so you never miss out and also
do not forget to follow me over on tick
tock and instagram at abby's kitchen oh
boy
where do we start we have a lot to
unpack here folks but i do want to kick
things off with a classic diet review
from the man behind the healthy ketosis
program who insists you need to do keto
and intermittent fasting to be younger
thinner happier smarter and less
diseases that's quite a tall order there
bud i don't know what you're talking
about but my gut says no but let's take
a look at what dr burke himself eats
apparently every single day from his
video with over a million views i will
usually get up about 5 30 in the morning
and i will have
coffee a very small cup of coffee it's
organic
and i put
cream in there whole cream and it's
grass-fed organic
half a teaspoon of xylitol
so i will drink that and then i'll have
about four of my nutritional yeast
tablets okay i i just feel good when i
when i take this
i get up early i study nutrition
and during the time i might have a
toccino which is a
non-decaffeinated alternative coffee
type drink
or some more tea nutritional yeasts by
itself for breakfast
i'm a fan of nooch but this is such a
strange suggestion like it seems kind of
like a clunky way to squeeze in a plug
for a product from his supplement line
why not just put it in your eggs so my
first meal is at 1 30 and of course i
love eggs there are pasture raised
organic eggs i put sea salt and pepper
and they're fried in butter in addition
i'll do six slices of bacon or three
sausages or two grass-fed hot dogs okay
with the eggs that's a lot of saturated
fat and salt in one go listen like i am
a huge fan of eggs and i'm also not
opposed to any of these ultra processed
meats in moderation but it does seem
ironic that he advocates eating two hot
dogs a day yet his website explicitly
differentiates his healthy ketosis
program approach from the traditional
keto plan by suggesting you avoid
processed foods grass-fed or farmer's
market it doesn't really matter like
these are all still ultra processed
foods that should be enjoyed in
moderation because in excess they have
been linked to things like heart disease
metabolic syndrome cancer and all-cause
mortality and this is just one of many
examples where berg continually
contradicts his own advice now i'll do
four ounces of cheese and sometimes i'll
throw some olives in there but i'm a
little spoiled with cheese okay so this
is the type of cheese that i like and
this cheese is produced from sheep on a
mountaintop in france i would love to
know what would happen to mr berg here
if the sheep who produced his cheese
were not to come from a mountain top in
france
devastating effects i'm sure if i have
an avocado i will also add that in there
and that's pretty much my meal and then
right after the meal i may consume about
four tablespoons of almond butter with
celery
or
pecans okay so if you're going to go
keto i say this is where you want to put
your money i would love to see a greater
emphasis on some of these plant-based
sources of fat which provide the
benefits of fiber and phytonutrients
with less saturated fat sodium and
nitrates again i'm not saying to not
have your hot dogs or your bacon but
rather to shift the proportion of our
fat sources to plant-based where we can
but i mean even still four eggs six
rashers of bacon half a brick of cheese
olives an avocado quarter cup of almond
butter pecans and dairy butter all
together seems like a lot of fat for the
old gut to process at once which is
naturally the slowest macronutrient to
digest most folks would not feel so good
so i will add some my electrolyte powder
wheatgrass juice powder in a mason jar
shake it up and drink that down it seems
to give me some good energy through the
afternoon so i want to clarify this
electrolytes and powders do not give you
energy calories do and specifically for
folks who are not in ketosis carbs are
the energy source of choice i just think
as a professional burke needs to be a
little more cautious about some of the
claims that he makes about supplements
that he sells himself electrolytes are
however helpful for some when doing keto
or fasting because the drop in insulin
can increase water and electrolyte loss
so if you're feeling some of the
symptoms of hyponatremia like headaches
lightheadedness fatigue nausea and
muscle cramps it's worth seeing if a
little extra sodium can help wheatgrass
on the other hand isn't stimulating nor
does it contain many energizing calories
or carbs but if anything it contains
some micronutrients and it probably
offers something kind of flavored to sip
on in an otherwise kind of monotonous
day so maybe that alone may offer the
feeling of vitality and life now about 5
30 is when i'll eat dinner okay i'll
have a huge salad i'm talking like about
10 cups okay all at once and i don't do
spinach i do other types of lettuce
leaves and cabbage
cut bell pepper i'll stick sometimes an
avocado on there maybe some other
vegetables sometimes pork rinds and
seeds roasted seeds that are salty with
sea salt okay so then i'll have my
grass-fed beef or pork sausage which is
from the farmer's market again
wild caught salmon as my protein and
sometimes for dinner i'll have the
summer sausage probably half of this
with cheese 10 cups oh dear lord like
again i'm happy to see some vegetables
going on but this diet is screaming in
digestion and bloat
and this is one of the many reasons why
combining keto and a very short
intermittent fasting eating window is
often bad news bears without any carbs
we're looking at needing to eat large
amounts of very slow digesting fats and
high volume fibrous foods all at once
just to meet your nutrient needs and
that is not gonna feel good or even be
safe necessarily for the vast majority
of his seven million subscribers listen
if you're absolutely convinced by the
benefits of keto or fasting for you they
can absolutely be had without needing to
go to such extremes and that's it folks
that's what berg eats in a day
apparently every single day and to my
comment section warriors coming at me oh
but that's not his most recent one night
a day i got you babes because i watched
that one too and it's pretty much almost
identical like same same different year
but with a little less commentary and
that just goes to show how painfully
monotonous this way of eating can be in
his more recent video he includes a
disclaimer that
i can eat the same thing every single
day and i assume that is the case at the
end of the day there are only so many
options when you need to meet your
calorie needs on such a limited number
of allowed foods but it's important to
note that diet variety is actually
really important for long-term health
not to mention the health of our
microbiome so this is just one of the
many reasons why i would never recommend
a diet as restrictive as this for the
general population i also think that to
share what you eat personally with a
disclaimer that you know this is just
how i eat is one thing i am actually not
against intermittent fasting or the keto
diet for the right person if it works
for you and you feel good eating that
way amazing like you do you but when a
health professional's personal diet
becomes the only diet they promote and
prescribe we're playing in grossly
unprofessional waters no nutrition
professional would only recommend a
singular way to eat our job is to shelve
our own bias acknowledge that all bodies
are unique and to take into
consideration an individual's
preferences budget lifestyle morals
culture and unique health conditions and
concerns we need to meet people where
they are but burke's pages are
overwhelmingly slanted to cherry pick
and present a strict keto intermittent
fasting lifestyle as the key to good
health he also is known to completely
ignore the body of evidence to further
his personal agenda and opinion so for
example burke states that the keto diet
will decrease your bad ldl cholesterol
but meanwhile a large 2013 systematic
review actually found it to do the
opposite further a 2019 review found
that keto diets are not superior to
other methods of weight loss but rather
they have low retention rates have
negative side effects and are associated
with an increased risk of cardiovascular
mortality so instead of citing the best
evidence on these topics that we have he
cites one super small study with like 66
obese patients aka not the general
population that had a positive ldl
effect it is scientific fact that's not
how we do science people that's not how
we do research and that's not the only
thing the knowledge doc as he calls
himself has been known to give dubious
advice about in his video on why you
shouldn't eat 100 whole grains in your
diet he puts a bunch of scary words on
the screen like increases weight gain
fatty liver and cholesterol malnutrition
with 10.9 million deaths under 5 years
old like that's frightening but
meanwhile literally all the evidence
that we have to date points towards the
benefits of eating whole grains for
things like cholesterol weight
management and longevity like the
evidence in support of whole grains of
all things is pretty indisputable hard
stop in another video he shares the best
ways to get rid of love handles kicking
off by saying this the medical term for
love handles is a muffin top
i'm pretty sure that's not the medical
term but anyways in this video he
insists a bunch of exercises will help
you get rid of your love handles for
good but fails to mention that you can't
spot train your body fat deposits
without losing weight overall like that
should have been what the video said you
can't spot train i have to give the
guy's team credit for his click bait
talent but when the content itself is
also like total bs i get pissed i am so
freaking pissed we also have to mention
that a lot of the supplements study
brands and cells are largely not
evidence-based take his blood sugar
support for example which i do feel is
kind of crossing an ethical line in a
lot of ways healthy people don't need
supplements to fix their blood sugars
and folks who do need support because
they have diabetes or insulin resistance
should be working with their health care
team on an appropriate safe strategy
taking freeze-dried grass-fed bovine
pancreas is not a safe or evidence-based
way to fix your pancreas in fact there's
no evidence on the safety of this for
humans and the only other product that i
could see that uses bovine pancreas is
in dog food i don't want to yuck
anyone's yum but
no i also think it's important to note
that my team and i looked but found no
mention of third party testing on any of
his supplements which if you're a
regular abby's kitchen viewer you know
should be red flag number one and it
gets even more dangerous than this he's
been accused of spreading misinformation
linking vaccines to autism which is a
dangerous assertion that has been
thoroughly thoroughly debunked he also
shares tips on what to do when your
child does have autism including
surprise surprise go keto cut out grains
intermittent fast and detox from heavy
metals
honestly the fact that google hasn't
de-indexed this guy's website is
irresponsible as
ultimately this is what happens when
healthcare professionals overstep their
professional boundaries and scope of
practice i never want to disrespect the
work of any allied health professional
or paint them all with the same brush
but it's people like dr berg who give
chiropractics a bad reputation let's get
one thing straight chiropractors are not
dietitians and while they can use the
term doctor they are also not medical
doctors
and this is obviously very deceiving and
confusing to the public which is part of
the reason why he was reprimanded in
2007. there were a number of grievances
including selling bogus and potentially
dangerous techniques and tests giving
out advice outside of his scope and
constantly branding himself as doctor
without clarifying that he was a
chiropractor not an md again no offense
to chiropractors i know there are a ton
of talented and evidence-based
practitioners out there but i do wish
that they had a different designation
that didn't lead to this confusion same
with nds who i also support but whose
approach and scope are very different
compared to mds ultimately i rarely
watch a youtube channel that fills me
with such rage most of the time when i
critique the misinformation i see from
influencers on youtube i feel some
personal empathy and compassion because
most influencers have just been misled
on their wellness journeys themselves
while they still should be held
responsible for their content i often
think they genuinely don't mean to do
harm but people like dr berg should and
do
no better he was taught his scope he was
taught how to read interpret ensight
research he was taught he is to do no
harm but with over 7 million vulnerable
subscribers i see a lot of potential
harm so please if you see one of his
videos pop up in your feed scroll on by
like nobody's got time for science
denial and on that note that is all that
i have for you guys today if you like
this video be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below on what or
who you'd like to see your view next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]